I want to show you a few optimization
algorithms that are faster than gradient
descent in order to understand those
algorithms you need to be able to use
something called exponentially weighted
averages also called exponentially
weighted moving averages in statistics
let's first talk about that and it will
use this to build out two most
sophisticated optimization algorithms so
even though I now live in the United
States I was born in London so for this
example I got the daily temperature from
London from last year so on January 1st
temperature was 40 degrees Fahrenheit
and I know most the world uses a Celsius
system but I guess Olivia United States
which uses Fahrenheit so that's four
degrees Celsius and on January second it
was 90 degrees Celsius and so on and
then about halfway through the year a
year has 365 days so this would be
sometimes day number 118 would be
sometime in late May I guess 160 degrees
Fahrenheit which is 15 degrees Celsius
and so on so start to get near warmer to
one summer and it was colder in January
so you plot the data you end up with
this with day one being sometime in
January that you know being the
beginning of summer and that's the end
of the year kind of late December so
this would be January of January first
as you middle the Year approaching
summer and this would be the data from
the end of the year so this need to look
a little bit noisy and if you want to
compute the trends kind of the local
average or a moving average of the
temperature here's what you can do let's
initialize V zero equals zero and then
on every day we're going to average it
with a weight of 0.9 times whatever is
the previous value plus 0.1 times the
that day's temperature so theta one here
would be the temperature from this first
day and on a second day we're again
going to take a weighted average
so 0.9 times of the previous value plus
0.1 times today's temperature
so on v2 plus 0.1 times theta 3 and so
on and the more general formula is V on
a given day is 0.9 times V from the
previous day plus 0.1 times the
temperature of that day so if you
compute this and plot it in red this is
what you get you get a moving average or
what's called an exponentially weighted
average of the daily temperature so
let's look at the equation we had from
the previous slide it was VT equals
previously we had 0.9 do not turn that
into parameter beta beta times BT minus
1 plus and appreci with 0.1 then turn
that into 1 minus beta times theta T so
previously we had beta equals 0.9 it
turns out that for reasons we'll go into
later when you compute this you can
think of VT as approximately averaging
over something like 1 over 1 minus beta
days temperature so for example when
beta equals 0.9 you could think of this
as averaging over the last 10 days
temperature and that was the red line
now let's try something else let's say
it beta to be very close to 1 this is
0.98 then if you look at 1 over 1 minus
0.98 this is equal to 50 so this is zeal
think of this is averaging over roughly
the last 50 days temperature and if you
plot that you get this green line so
notice a couple things with this very
high value of beta the plot you get is
much smoother because you're now
averaging over more days of temperature
so the curve is just you know less
Wiggly is now smoother but on the flip
side the curve is now shifted further to
the right because you're now averaging
over a much larger window of temperature
and by averaging over a larger window
this formula is exponentially weighted
average formula it adapts more slowly
when the temperature changes right so
there's just a little more latency and
the reason for that is when beta 0 0.98
then it's giving a lot of weight to the
previous value and a much smaller weight
just point 0 to 2 whatever you're seeing
right now so when the temperature
changes or in term she goes up or down
this exponentially weighted average just
a decimal slowly when beta is so large
now let's try another value that you set
data to another extreme let's say it is
0.5 then this by the formula we have on
the right this is something like
averaging over just two days temperature
and you plot that to get this yellow
line and by averaging only over two days
temperature you have a muchness as if
you're averaging over much shorter
window so you're much more noisy much
more susceptible to outliers but this
adapts much more quickly to the
temperature changes so this formula is
how you implement an exponentially
weighted average again is called an
exponentially weighted moving average
industry 2/6 literature and I'm going to
call it exponentially weighted average
for short and by varying this parameter
or later we'll see essentially hyper
parameter of your learning algorithm you
can get slightly different effects and
it will usually be some value in between
their workspace that gives you the red
curve which you're maybe looks like a
better average in temperature than
either the green or the yellow curve you
now know the basics of how to compute
exponentially weighted averages in the
next video let's gain a bit more
intuition about what is doing